hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
we'll do some advanced examples of
multiplying numbers by drawing lines
we'll cover five topics
we'll do an example where the digits are
different
another one where it contains the number
nine
we'll cover negative numbers
complex and imaginary numbers
and we'll do an example of binary
multiplication
let's say you want to do 122 times 13.
we'll draw the 122 as we normally do
and for the 13 we want to make sure that
the three is aligned on the right
so we'll draw this number
by drawing the three lines first all the
way on the right side
we'll leave some space and we'll draw
one line
now we make our groupings and we'll just
count as normal
there are six lines six dots here
eight dots
in the middle they're five
and one dot
so you can do
multiplications where the digits are
different just remember to align the
second number starting all the way on
the right
let's do 19 times 11.
for the one we'll draw one line
for the nine we could draw nine lines
but that will get cumbersome and you
also end up having to count a lot of
dots
so instead we'll draw one line
and to emphasize that it's a nine we'll
draw it in a different color and we'll
make it nine times the thickness
now we draw the other number 11 in the
other direction
we'll make our groupings
here we have one dot
but it's an intersection with the nine
line so it's a big dot
and we have to remember that counts for
nine so this one dot is really nine dots
in the middle we have one small dot and
one big dot
and the big dot really counts for nine
small dots
so we have nine plus one which is ten
on the left side we just have one dot
we will carry this one over
and that gives us our answer two hundred
209
let's say you wanted to do x minus 2y
times x minus 3y
we'll draw the x with one line
and for the negative 2y
we'll draw two lines
and we'll just remember that each blue
line represents a negative y
for the other number we'll draw the
lines in the other way
and here again we have three lines which
are each negative y
we make our groupings
here we have six dots
and to know what the dots represent we
look at the color of the lines
we have the intersection of two blue
lines
and each blue line is a negative y
so we'll have a negative y times the
negative y which is y squared
so that means we have six y squared
in the center we have five dots
and this is the intersection of a black
line which is x
and a blue line which is negative y
so x times negative y is negative x y
and therefore we have negative five x y
finally we have one dot which is the
intersection of two black lines
each of which is x
so we'll have an x squared
and that gives us our answer which is x
squared minus 5xy plus 6y squared
we can modify this example to show how
we can use the same technique for
complex
numbers let's say that y will be equal
to the imaginary number i
our diagram here is exactly the same
except that instead of having a y we've
substituted i
so we'll have x squared negative five x
i and six i squared
when we write our final answer we just
have to remember that i squared is
negative one
so we have x squared minus 5 x i minus
6.
in our final example we'll do binary
multiplication which is numbers in base
2.
let's say we want to do one zero one
times one one
we'll draw one line
leave some space and draw a zero line
and then we'll draw one more line
and for the other number we'll make sure
we start out by
drawing the one on the right side
and we'll leave some space to draw the
other one
we make our groupings
on the right we have one dot
in the next grouping we'll only have one
dot we don't count the intersections of
the zero line
in the middle again we have one dot
and on the left we have one dot
and that gives us our answer so we can
actually use this method
when we're doing multiplication in base
two
i'll mention that if you do
multiplication of base two whenever you
have two or more dots you're going to
have to carry over and the rule is
slightly different but you can adapt
this method
to do base 2 or even any other number
base
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can also
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
on twitter preshtalwalkar or get my
ebooks and amazon